to form the recipes repository first
I'll visit Larry's repository on github
you can find the link for this
repository in the instructors notes now
I'll zoom into this part of the page and
click the fork button here then a copy
of the repository is made on my own
github profile now when I visit my
profile I can see the recipes repository
here now I'd like to be able to edit
these recipes on my own computer rather
than just on the github website so I'll
also want to clone this fork for recipes
it doesn't matter so much where I edit
but if I were writing code I would
definitely want to be able to edit on my
own computer the github page contains
the URL I should clone over here so I'll
copy that URL and paste it into my git
clone command
now I'll CD into the new repository and
you might think that I need to add the
fork on github as a remote so that I'll
be able to push to it but actually when
you clone a repository it automatically
sets up a remote pointing to the
repository you come from I'll verify
that by running git remote - V and sure
enough there's a remote called origin
and the URL points to my repository on
github finally since I want Sarah to be
able to collaborate with me she'll need
permission to push to this repository
I'll add her as a collaborator by going
to settings clicking collaborators and
then adding her github username which is
solid gel 42 you won't need to add Sarah
as a collaborator to your repository but
you can't add anyone who you would like
to be able to push to your repository
and then I'll need to click the add
collaborator button now for Clara's
repository to your own github profile
don't fork the one on my profile since
I'll be making changes to my fork
throughout this lesson and you don't
want those changes again you can find
the link to Larry's repository in the
instructors notes once you've created
the fork clone your fork and run git
remote - V and paste the output into
this box